ايضا مشاهدينا في فقره ضيف اليوم سنتحدث
عن جوله زلانسكي الاوروبيه التي بداها من
بريطانيا ثم بالامس باريس واليوم هو موجود
في بروكسال صباحا كلمه امام البرلمان
الاوروبي يدعى فيها الى المزيد من الدعم
الاوروبي لاوكرانيا وفي هذه الاثناء يعقد
مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس الفاضيه الاوروبيه
ورئيس الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا الحديث
والتركيز عن الدعم الاوروبي العقوبات الى
ما هنالك كل ذلك سنتحدث عنه مع حميد
الكفاني البحث والكاتب السياسي في
العلاقات الدوليه مرحبا واهلا بك استاذ
حميد
اليوم زلنسكي منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه على
بلاده يقوم بجوله اوروبيه يتجول بين عواصم
القرار من بريطانيا الى باريس وهو اليوم
في بروكسيل ليحشد المزيد من الدعم دعم
السياسي دعم الاوروبي الدعم الجماهيري
هذه الجوله برايك
ستعزز قوه اوكرانيا اكثر في حربها ضد
روسيا
تحيه لك وللمشاهدين ابتداءنا وصحح الاسم
الكفائي
من ناحيه ما تفضلتي به
بالتاكيدنسكي واوكرانيا تحتاج لان تتواصل
مع اوروبا فاوروبا هي المعنيه الاولى
بدعم اوكرانيا لان اوروبا تشعر بالخطر من
التوجه الروسي نحو ضم الارض
بالقوه والاعتلاء على الدول الاخرى وهذا
ليس الاعتداء الاول على اوكرانيا فقد
اقتطع منها جزء مهم وهو شبه جزيره القرم
كذلك جورجيا تعرضت الى اقتطاع اراضي منها
الان كشف رئيس اليونسكي
ان مالدوفا ايضا تتعرض هناك خطه
اطلعت عليها اوكرانيا اعترضت اشارات
ومعلومات من روسيا لتدمير
الديمقراطيه في مولدوفا
وجعلها دوله تابعه اذا اوروبا معنيه بهذا
التوجه الروسي الذي يستهدف اوروبا
واوكرانيا تقدم تضحيات كبيره
بالدماء والخسائر البشريه
والماديه والعسكريه لذلك لاوروبا مصلحه في
دعم اوكرانيا
وبالتاكيد زياره زيلينسكي هي تحديدا
لطلب طائرات
لان الحرب لا يمكن ان
تتفوق فيها اوكرانيا دون وجود قوه جويه
فاعله الاوروبيون بالتكيس سوف يقدمون له
لاوكرانيا الطائرات ولكن كما قال رئيس
الوزراء في بريطانيا ريشيسونك ان التدريب
يجب ان يحصل اولا والتدريب على الطائرات
يحتاج الى وقت وهذه مساله
يجب ان ينظر وانا متاكد ان هناك الكثير من
المحادثات والامور تجري في السر لان هذه
قضايا عسكريه ولا يمكن الاعلان عن كل شيء
طيب استاذ حميد الكفائي بدايه في بدايه
هذه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
الكثير من الخبراء من يعني من الاختصاصين
في الشان اعتبروا بان اوروبا ضعيفه الموقف
الاوروبي ضعيف اوكرانيا وحيده اليوم الروس
يثبتون بانهم اقوى ولكن مع مرور الاشهر
كيف ترى بانه كفه الميزان هل برايك تبدلت
هل نرى اليوم بان الموقف الاوروبي اقوى
الرساله الاوروبيه التي يراد ايصالها الى
الروس هل برايك باتت اقوى سواء من خلال
الدعم العسكري
الذي يتم ارساله الى اوكرانيا او الذي يتم
الدرس ارساله كما قلت الطائرات او من خلال
استقبال الرئيس الاوكراني بهذه الصوره
اليوم في العواصم الاوروبيه
هذا اقل ما يمكن ان تفعله اوروبا الان
استقبال الرئيس وتقديم السلاح لان
اوكرانيا الان حقيقه تدافع عن اوروبا كما
قال الرئيس زلينسكي نعم الموقف الاوروبي
اقوى بكثير من السابق كان هناك تردد سابقا
في تقديم الدبابات مثلا الى اوكرانيا ولكن
اقتنعت اوروبا وامريكا بان الدبابات
ضروريه لانه اوكرانيا تريد ان
تخرج الروس من اراضيها ولا يمكنها ان تفعل
ذلك دون او وجود
دبابات
ومدرعات قويه مثل
الامريكيه هذه ضروريه كان هناك تردد سابقا
الان لا يوجد تردد
حول الدبابات ولكن هناك بعض التساؤلات حول
القوه الجويه وحاول تقديم الطائرات ولكن
حتى هذه المساله سوف تذلل
مطمئن ان اوروبا لن تسمح على روسيا
بالانتصار في اوكرانيا اوكرانيا ستكون
الدوله التي تواجه روسيا نيابه عن اوروبا
وتحد من هذه النزعه العسكريه
التي لا تتلائم مع الديمقراطيه الاوروبيه
لا تتلائم مع المجتمع الدولي ومع العصر
هذه نزعه قديمه لا يمكن ان تسمح بها ولا
يمكن ان يسمح بها العالم في الحقيقه حتى
الصين التي يعتقد كثيرون بانها لديها
علاقات نعم لديها علاقات مع روسيا ولكنها
غير غير مطمئنه وغير مرتاحه للتوجه الروسي
بالغزو العسكري عاصين تحاول ان تنفتح
اقتصاديه يعني بالامس ايضا الرئيس
الامريكي في خطاب الاتحاد
ركز كثيرا في كلمته ايضا
اوكرانيا وكيف ان بلاده ستقوم بكل ما يجب
القيام به لدعم اوكرانيا يعني هل ترى ايضا
انه الموقف الامريكي مع الموقف الاوروبي
باتا موحد منسق بشكل اكبر اليوم تجاه هذه
الحرب
بمرور الزمن بالتاكيد التنسيق يزداد قوه
ويزداد دقه والكل يعلم ان هناك مصلحه
اوروبيه مصلحه
للمجتمع الغربي بشكل عام والمجتمع الحر
وللعالم للدول الصغيره والكبيره بان لا
يعتدى على دوله مثل اوكرانيا
الولايات المتحده معنيه بالدرجه الاولى
بهذه المساله وهي الدوله الاكثر قدره على
تقديم المساعدات لاوكرانيا واعتقد انها لن
تتردد في تقديم المساعدات المطلوبه
المطلوب الان هو ان تستعد اوكرانيا لحرب
طويله الامد وان تكون قادره
عسكريا على مواجهه الروس وعلى الحاق
الهزيمه بالروس وهذا يتاتى عبر التدريب
وعبر تقديم الاسلحه وتقديم المساعدات
الاقتصاديه
اوكرانيا الان تحارب نيابه عن العالم
الغربي عن المجتمع الدولي في الحقيقه لذلك
الولايات المتحده واوروبا معنيه بالدرجه
الاولى
بمساعده اوكرانيا واعتقد ان اوكرانيا سوف
تتمكن في الربيع
المقبل او في الصيف من ان تستعيد بعض
اراضيها على الاقل وان روسيا تدرك يوما
بعد اخر انها لا تستطيع ان تهزم العالم لا
تستطيع ان تبتزل العالم الاسلحه النوويه
العديد من دول العالم الذي اسلحه نوويه
اوكرانيا بالمناسبه كانت القوه النوويه
الثالثه في العالم بعد الولايات المتحده
وروسيا حتى تخلت عن سلاحها النووي عام 94
في اتفاقيه بودابست مقابل صيانه سيادتها
ومن الدول الموقعه على صيانه سياده
اوكرانيا هي روسيا لذلك العالم كله له
مصلحه في ان تنتصر اوكرانيا وان تتراجع
روسيا عن هذا التوجه العسكري غير المرغوب
فيه في العالم المعاصر شكرا جزيلا لك
البحث والكتب السياسي حميد الكفاء على هذه
المداخله